welcome to the show everybody here we
are now 15 days at is 15 or 15 days
until Christmas and a quick reminder
that if you don't have your tree and
your Christmas decorations up by now you
are officially a part of the war on
Christmas you are waging a war on
Christmas you are a belligerent on the
side of the anti-christmas army that's
what you're doing and I mean think about
it Starbucks
okay Starbucks had their Christmas stuff
up or their holiday stuff anyway but we
all know what they're doing they had it
up before Thanksgiving are you really
gonna let star but are you gonna be out
Christmas
buy Starbucks of all things Christians
always complain about Starbucks but
they've got they they've got they got
more Christmas spirit than 90% of
Christians today it's it's it's a
disgrace I can tell you in my
neighborhood very few of the houses
right now and here we are with December
10th right we are well into December we
are I mean we're it's it's we've already
lost a week of December and many most of
the houses in my neighborhood no
decorate not even a wreath on the door
except for one house that has
inflatables and that's really the
inflatable decorations are even more
offensive than having no decoration of
all at all which is why under my regime
of course every house Christian or not
will be required to decorate for
Christmas and the displays must include
white Christmas lights a nativity scene
inflatables orb and colored lights our
band Christmas cheer is mandatory
because I'm going to end the war on
Christmas with an iron fist
and look I'm not saying that you can't
add additional decorations to go along
with the white Christmas lights and the
nativity scene in fact you should but
the white lights and the nativity are
staples and and everything has to sort
of work with that it has to be
harmonious and agents from my merriment
enforcement department meed will conduct
of course random checks and make sure
that your your display is tasteful and
it all works together and if it isn't
then your house will be bulldozed on the
spot
with all of the inhabitants still inside
and again this is all just being done to
make sure that everybody has a nice
Christmas but you have to break a few
eggs to make a to make an egg nog as
they say all right so we have a lot to
talk about today obviously yesterday was
a show dedicated to the porn problem and
me explaining my arguments for banning
or regulating porn as you might expect
tons of feedback on that tons of emails
about it and actually I've been I've
been very surprised by the emails from
the show I did yesterday pleasantly
surprised whereas the response on
Twitter if you go to Twitter you can
still see it it's 95 percent negative
the response there if not 99% and the
feedback on I've written now two pieces
about two columns for The Daily wire
calm and and the feedback on those on
those articles if you read the comments
again like 95% negative but the emails
that I got after at Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com the emails that I got after
the show I did yesterday by and large
very positive lots of men who say they
struggle with porn addictions and and
agree with me lots of women whose
husbands and and sons have been caught
up in it and also agree that it's a
problem that needs to be addressed so
that feedback has been pretty
fascinating and the difference in the
feedback from you know one forum to the
next has been interesting as well I
don't know exactly how to account for it
other than to say that that maybe the
people who are anti porn are ironically
in our culture in a situation where they
feel ashamed to say it publicly so the
people who are pro porn that they have
no shame about saying I love poor and
poor is great and they'll say it
publicly they'll write it on the
internet but the people who are against
it
are the ones hiding in dark corners
whispering sending you the feeling they
have to send private messages because
they don't want to say it publicly in
fact several of the messages and emails
I've gotten have had that disclaimer of
saying yeah I really I support you I
like which I didn't want to say this
publicly because I don't want people
coming after
me but here's my thought this is this no
it should be the other way around you're
saying that you're against smut an
obscenity that's not a shameful position
to take I'm not blaming those who are
nervous about saying it publicly what
I'm saying is this is this is this is
how backwards everything is in our
culture where now if you're not in favor
of smut and obscenity that's the
shameful thing
so we'll get to all that well we'll talk
about we'll continue the porn discussion
in the email portion of the show but
before we get to that I want to begin
with actress
Jameela Jamil from NBC's the good place
well she's recently been on on social
media bragging about her abortion
speaking of a lack of shame she's been
bragging about abortion attacking
pro-lifers but her most recent post
about her abortions has been I think was
very instructive and revealing so here's
what she said
and this again is after many other posts
about her abortions where she's
celebrating it and so forth then she
says receiving thousands of messages
about how I made a mistake having an
abortion seven years ago now I must be a
miserable person I am in fact a happy
thriving multi-millionaire madly in love
with free time good sleep and a
wonderful career and life but thanks for
checking then when she was asked about
babies who have a heartbeat and are
viable outside the womb asked well what
about them would you say at least they
should be spared
she said if it's at the cost of a woman
/ little girl / rape or incest victim /
disabled person who doesn't want to put
their life and body through the hell of
through hell for a baby they don't want
and can't take care of yep every time
the choice is the landlord's not the
tenant nor the neighbors and at another
point she went into the whole familiar
stick about Oh Pro lifers are only pro
birth you don't care about babies after
they're born okay now a few things
they're going through these first of all
as for the pro birth stick well I I
don't even think I need to spend time on
it this is the laziest
argument from pro-abortion bee and they
make a lot of lazy arguments but this is
the laziest possible argument you're Pro
first of all what is there anything
wrong with being pro birth of course yes
I am pro birth I am in favor of babies
who are conceived being born I think if
a baby is conceived and is not born
whether because of being murdered by a
human or a miscarriage I think that's a
terrible thing I am very much in favor
of every conceived a child being born so
I
so yes Pro birth I wear that label
proudly but of course there are many
other problems here one being that the
people who say the pro-lifers don't care
about babies after they're born they
have no evidence no statistics at all
okay it's not like they have statistics
proving that pro lifers are less likely
to adopt less likely to give to charity
less likely to volunteer their time they
don't have that in fact if they looked I
can guarantee you they'll find the
opposite many pro lifers adopt children
many pro lifers are very charitable
donate to the poor you'll help the sick
in the needy is a very common thing
among Pro lifers and of course it is
because if you're a pro-lifer you're
already spending a lot of your time
defending people who cannot speak for
themselves so that's gonna come from a
place of compassion this is the problem
the pro-abortion people have they really
desperately want to believe that Pro
lifers are pro-life because of some
selfish self-serving desire but what's
how is it selfish and self-serving for
someone to say that I don't think you
should kill babies up i don't benefit
from that when i sit here and say you
shouldn't kill babies i don't benefit at
all if i advocate before pro-life
legislation i don't benefit from it it's
not like I'm saying it for my sake I'm
already born now I'm not saying that I
sacrifice a lot either by advocating for
I don't think I do but I know it's it's
not self-serving the pro-abortion case
is self-serving and they know it because
what they're saying is no if I conceive
a child I want to have the ability to
kill it because you know if it doesn't
because I'm more concerned about my
lifestyle so they have the self-serving
and selfish perspective they know it and
so they're trying to find some way to
make us into the selfish ones and it's
just absurd it doesn't work so this
claim Pro birth not pro-life there's no
evidence for that no statistics none at
all zero and and it doesn't it makes no
difference anyway you know if if
somebody says hey we shouldn't we
shouldn't murder homeless people I'm
against murdering the homeless would we
say to that person
well that opinion doesn't count if
they're not you know volunteering at a
soup kitchen
what so I unless I volunteer in a soup
kitchen I can't say don't kill homeless
people is it not just morally correct
that it's wrong to kill homeless but
isn't that a morally correct statement
regardless of how I spend my time
regardless of how charitable I
personally am and yes I should be a
charitable person but even if I'm not
even if I'm a selfish sob I'm still
correct that you shouldn't kill the
homeless and you have done nothing to
disprove my anti killing the homeless
position by accusing me arbitrarily and
without evidence by the way of being you
know a selfish hypocritical uncharitable
person all right um I thought her thing
about the Landlord and Tenant was very
interesting putting aside that it's a
totally deranged way of looking at the
relationship between mother and child
and this is another thing that
pro-abortion people are desperately
trying to find some analogy because they
realized that the analogy of having a
child is like having a parasite or
tapeworms or it's like having cancer
they realize how cruel and and
just unfeeling and and and and
everything that comparison sounds and
dehumanizing so they're trying to find
some other comparison and this is what
she comes up with it's like Landlord and
Tenant well this is interesting because
I can pretty much guarantee you that
this person Jameela Jamil doesn't
actually believe that real actual
landlords can evict their real tenants
for any reason they see fit so she
certainly doesn't believe that tenants
that landlords can kill their tenants
which is what now she's saying that it's
like a landlord-tenant relationship and
so that allows the landlord to kill the
tenant in this case but in a situation
where I'm a landlord and I own a house
and I've rented it out as apartments I'm
pretty sure she's gonna tell me that if
I get tired of one of the tenants in the
attendant living in apartment 1b
I'm pretty sure she doesn't think I can
just walk in there and kill him
but not only that I can I am very sure
that she would also say given that she's
a member of the progressive left she
would also say I don't have the right to
evict him for any reason I see fit so
for example I can't if I if he's a
homosexual she's gonna say I can't evict
them for that transgender I can't evict
him for that so she uses the the
landlord tenant analogy to justify a
mother killing a child when in fact she
believes that landlords have very little
Authority or power over their tenants
and in fact she believes that tenants
may have a right to remain in their
landlords property against the
landlord's will that's her pert her
belief so her analogy that she uses that
she uses destroys her own case because
there are
times when yeah the the eat you have a
you have a land you have some attendant
in a in a building there are times when
the the tenant may have the right to
continue living there on the landlord's
property against the landlord's will in
fact I would even agree with that in
some circumstances because this is a
contractual arrangement and the point is
that the landlord can't just tear up the
contract at any moment he has to honor
it
well I think you could also argue if we
have taking her analogy here
okay well the tenant in the mother's
womb number one didn't choose to move in
there that tenant was put there by the
landlord in this case which is the
mother and the father okay they're the
ones who put that child in that
apartment it wasn't a choice made by the
by the by the tenant in this case and I
would say that now we have a contractual
arrangement here you have put that
tenant there and now that tenant gets to
be there through three trimesters of
pregnancy and then we have the stuff
about how happy and wonderful life is
how rich she is and so on
good rule of thumb here if someone is
publicly insisting that they're happy
they aren't happy and the problem is
that all the things she mentions that
are comforts luxuries okay these things
don't bring joy you know it's nice to
have money but nobody finds joy in money
which is why infamously rich celebrities
are often depressed miserable
drug-addicted
self-destructive having a lot of free
time being able to sleep in yeah that's
very nice that's that's enjoyable but
that's not joyful you aren't filled with
a deep sense of joy and contentment
because you have free time in fact
usually if you have too much free time
you get bored and
leapin it I mean the irony is that only
parents who rarely sleep in can actually
take joy and sleeping in if you sleep in
every day then it's just part of your
life and you probably don't appreciate
it that much but parents who get one
chance in five months
to sleep in really really appreciate it
in fact they might find joy in it
because they don't get to do it very
often the other thing is that most of
what she mentioned aside from sleeping
in and free stuff but in free time the
other the other the other thing she
mentioned money career and so forth you
can have that with kids she could right
now have the career have the money have
the nice house and even have the free
time and the sleeping in probably
because she died her nanny if she wanted
to if she is a multimillionaire she
could have all that and also have a baby
she could have the nice house and the
nice house doesn't have to be
depressingly empty she could have the
joy of motherhood and everything else
that's the false choice that the
abortion industry presents they say well
you have to choose between the baby and
financial success in life and a nice
career and all of that well no you don't
have to choose of course if you did have
to choose and you had to choose between
a baby's life as a parent or the career
you want then the correct choice and
also the choice that is going to make
you happier in life ultimately and that
won't lead to a life of guilt which is
the life that jameelah is living whether
she says it or not the choice would be
to choose the child of course but my
point is you don't really have to even
choose between the two
you should prioritize your child over
your career over these other things but
you you can have both and this is this
is what's um this is what's funny
because feminists they're the ones
limiting women and saying no you got to
choose when it seems to me the more
empowering message for a woman is you
could have it all you don't have to
choose now you could be a mother and you
can go and live your life and do the
things that you want and
sooo your dreams you could do both you
might have to do it differently than you
imagined okay you might have to take a
more secure this route than you
originally thought but but that that
happens no matter what whether you have
a baby or not your life isn't going to
go exactly as you planned you're going
that you know you can have your goals
and your your dreams and your objectives
but it's not going to be a straight A to
B point A to point B right across as the
crow flies sort of route you're gonna
end up taking detours and doing all this
so that happens whether you have kids or
not but just because you have a child
you don't have to just throw those
dreams and goals out you don't have to
abandon them you might find as you grow
and and and you know as you grow older
as a person and you grow into your role
as a parent that your dreams and goals
change if they do they do but they don't
have to do all right um say what else
you're reading now from me pull this up
a disturbing story and I will I will
save you any images that might accompany
it except for the mental images which
fortunately I cannot save you from this
is an article on The Daily wire Amanda
pressure Giacomo says wearing a black
thong and buttless black dress hit
singer/songwriter and body positivity
icon Liz O torqued for the cameras while
standing courtside at a Los Angeles
Lakers game on Sunday evening the media
especially left slash feminists leaning
magazines and web sites gushed over the
singer's bare booty gyrating and those
who criticized the truth hurt singer for
being inappropriate considering NBA
games are frequented or frequented by
kids and families were dismissed as fat
phobic and sexist and then there's a
video there if you could see if you go
to the Daily wire but you probably don't
want to see Elle magazine gushed over
Liz OHS outfit and twerking moves and
praised her for her brazen confidence
the singer wore a shirt dress with the
back cutout so everyone could see the
black thong she was wearing with her
fishnet stockings then she flaunted it
when she tore
for the Jumbotron that is honestly the
kind of brazen confidence we should all
take into 20/20 the magazine said enews
titled their piece on the singers antics
lizzo is a true winner after twerking in
her thong outside of the lakers game and
then we go through other media outlets
that are similarly celebrating but i
think you you probably generally get the
idea so we have Liz oh the obese singer
who went to a Lakers game with a dress
with a big hole cut out around the butt
area wearing a thong now a few a few
obvious points here number one if a man
went out dressed like that we would all
just call him a pervert at a sexual
harasser okay so if you had a man doing
that we would all say this is this is
why we need the me to movement this is a
man who's in imposing himself on others
this is a man right and that's what we
would say and it would be true by the
way we would be totally it would be
accurate to say that a man who does that
is a pervert and a degenerate it's also
true when a woman does it so we're not
making exceptions there is no female
privilege here second point is that it's
on top of everything else
extremely unhygenic and disgusting that
you're sitting down on chairs that other
people are going to use we don't need to
get too graphic about that but here's
the main thing that jumps out at me and
it's kind of similar to what we just
talked about where you had a woman had
an abortion and now is insisting no I'm
happy guys I'm so happy you have no idea
how happy I am and it's it's similar
here where you have you have a woman
advertising in increasingly desperate
ways how confident she is in her body
this this is all this body positivity
and self-confidence most of it is people
who are desperate for attention and are
not
comfortable with themselves at all
actually if you're comfortable with
yourself and you go to a basketball game
you're just gonna wear normal clothing
you go to the game you're gonna sit
there you have a beer or something and
you're just gonna watch the game that's
if you're comfortable with yourself
that's what people who are comfortable
with themselves do they go about their
day there they don't they don't need to
stand out they don't need attention from
everybody they don't need to be
celebrated everywhere they go they don't
need to make a statement all the time
they just go about their day
that is what confident self-assured
people do someone who has no confidence
no self assurance someone who hates
themselves someone who desperately needs
the approval of others will do exactly
what lizzo does here will do anything
for attention that's that's the main
point most of what you see in from these
celebrities and pop culture of whether
it's women or men doing pulling stunts
like this to advertise how come
confident they are no it's just because
they this is a woman lizzo who is
addicted to attention and approval and
needs it so much from everybody it's
pathetic it's sad and the other problem
of course with body positivity is that
you shouldn't be positive about
everything about your body necessarily
if there's something that is unhealthy
and that you can control about your body
then no you shouldn't be positive about
it so being positive about morbid
obesity is like an alcoholic being
positive about liver damage it's like an
alcoholic going around celebrate I have
liver damage isn't it great has it has
an image of his damaged liver that are
you gonna Prince out and puts on a
t-shirt what where's it where's everyone
look at my damaged liver there's nothing
to be positive there you're destroying
yourself
doesn't mean you should hate yourself in
fact it means you should stop hating
yourself and you should you should start
respecting yourself and stop doing this
to yourself
so that there is there is a happy in
between but there is there is somewhere
in between
this body positivity I'm celebrating
everything about my body and hating
myself there is somewhere in between
where I have confidence in myself I'm
not looking for attention or approval I
don't hate myself but I also realize
that there are things about me that can
be improved and so I'm going to try to
improve those things
all right let's now get right to emails
because there's a bunch of them Matt
well show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com obviously I can't read all the
messages people have sent about the porn
topic but I'll do as many as I can this
is from Jerome I think JJ arom so I want
to say Jerome draw maybe I've been
listening to your show for a few months
and I agree with your views and love
your argument supporting them I'm so
glad that you came out and strongly
supported your view that porn should be
banned on the show yesterday I
especially appreciated your stance that
conservatism has its roots in morality
for a while now I have felt like my
morally conservative views are at odds
with some right wing ideas however the
way you explained it yesterday made so
much sense I feel it is not only a
victory for the left when we abandoned
what is good but also a victory for
Satan what do you feel needs to be done
to help steer the right back to a
foundation in moral thinking and
policymaking so as to avoid the weak
don't legislate morality position held
by so many today love to hear your
thoughts well I think people just need
to take a moment to think through their
own positions follow the thread of their
own thinking the idea that morality
shouldn't be a part of our policy
debates is not only dumb and weak but
also nonsensical because if you stop to
think about it for a moment you realize
how impossible it is to separate
morality from law
morality from policy you just can't do
it so I think people need to do the
intellectual work themselves I don't
know if there's a lot we can do to make
people think people need to be willing
to do that themselves this is from Trey
says dear Matt you do realize that you
just lost a lot of listeners right we we
don't tune in to hear you're insane
lectures about porn
well thanks Trey yeah I don't here's the
thing about that I don't care that much
you know you lose people you gain people
it's it's the way it goes
and now personally I don't really
understand that I would think if you
listen to this show it's because for
whatever reason you're interested in
what my opinions are not saying you
should be interested but that's why
you're here so then you hear an opinion
you don't agree with why would that make
you run away if it does fine I don't
know why it would have that effect
unless you come here because what you
really want to hear is your own opinions
shout it back out at you so I think
that's probably the case with you try
and end with a lot of other people they
listen to podcast or they watch cable
news and they all that they listen to
pundits they're not really interested in
what those people are saying what they
want to hear is what they already think
echoed back at them and so what I would
suggest is you could save a lot of time
and money if you just want to hear your
own opinions you could you know maybe
walk into a big you know maybe like a
big cavernous building and or a cave and
just shout your opinions and you'll hear
your opinions back in your ears through
the echo if that's all you're looking
for I mean nothing you could do is you
could just record your own opinions and
then play them back in your ears
soothing music as you go about your day
this is front but thanks for listening
this is from Lance says dear Matt I just
want to reach out to say that I agree
with you 100% when it comes to banning
porn
I myself have struggled with and still
struggle with porn if I remember
correctly I was introduced to porn at
around 11 started out as a complete
accident I looked at nude pictures at
first but then started watching
pornographic videos it's something that
I wish I never had access to and
something I wish never existed and I'm
ashamed to be addicted to it
Lance thanks for that feedback I've
there's a few other emails similar to
that which I'm gonna read as well you
know this is from Jacob said dear Matt
I've been struggling with porn addiction
and your episode on porn was amazing I
while I understand it's not the only
reason to rid our lives of porn your
comment that the viewer doesn't know if
the act is consensual it doesn't care
really hit me hard it's a hell of a
motivator to keep fighting the addiction
you are right porn does ruin lives
I was so desensitized I struggled to
have intimate moments with my wife I'm
now divorced I was exposed to porn at a
very young age though this was
pre-internet it became a lot easier to
gain access to to it with the internet
nobody warned me of the dangers of porn
the issues were not widely known and to
this day it has rarely talked about
society treats porn like as normal human
behavior but it's not this is not what
God intended and it can easily rip your
life apart thank you for taking the time
to get the word out I only wish more
people would this is from anonymous sis
hello sir big fan of your show I work in
a treatment facility that works with
male juvenile sex offenders I have
worked with around 20 young men most of
these young men have offended against a
younger sibling most of the clients I
meet come from broken families but what
every single one of them in common has
in common is they were all exposed to
pornography at a young age I realized
I'm making an argument to make
pornography illegal based on this will
be fallacious because the data is too
small but I think it's a testament how
destructive pornography really is you
don't have to be a biblical scholar heck
you don't even have to be a Christian to
see just how morally evil pornography is
I had 100% support legislation to make
poor and illegal I appreciate the work
you do thank you and I there's a ton of
emails like the ones I just read that's
just a sampling and I think it's it's a
really powerful testimony from people
who you know like this this email here
people that work with kids who've been
exposed to pornography have seen it then
you have men you know the first two
emails I read from four men who struggle
with thee of a man whose marriage was
destroyed by it these are really common
stories this is not these are not
exceptions this is not aberration this
is what porn is doing to families and to
people and to men and to women and the
children this is what it's doing all
across the country millions of cases of
it millions of examples so if you're
sitting there still trying to insist
that that you know this is a matter of
just between consenting adults and it's
not a big deal it's just images that it
doesn't really have any effect on
society I think you're trying to I think
you're hiding from what is clearly the
reality you're burying your head in the
proverbial sand this is from Marcus as
Matt you're the one who sounds like a
leftist right now someone can't disagree
with you without being branded a leftist
or a believer and leftist thought grow
up not all of your fans have to agree
with everything you say and if they
don't and if they don't you'll mark them
for being a leftist this is coming from
someone who listens every day and
someone who has not disagreed with you
yet until today stop with the shallow
branding and name-calling you don't
always have to be right also I agree
with the regulating porn strictly but
not outright banning well Marcus I think
I was pretty specific with the left
discharge I said that when a
conservative reflexively defends
hardcore porn which it sounds like
you're not but when when when one does
and many have yes that is a conservative
who has bought into leftism without even
knowing it and I stand by that there is
nothing in conservatism historically
that lines up behind a defense of
hardcore porn that's just not what
conservatism seeks to conserve also I
said it's a leftist claim it is a
leftist claim to say that the common
good is a subjective or relative concept
which it is because that is literally
relativism and relativism moral
relativism is the opposite of what
conservatism is again conservatism is
not seeking to conserve moral relativism
or hardcore porn or the the ability of
children to see smut on the Internet is
not what conservatism historically has
been looking to conserve I think that
lines up much much more with the left's
cultural agenda this is from let's see
this is from Abraham says you repeatedly
make the point that porn has zero good
and only bad influence but if you were
to take alcohol into consideration
alcohol is the same idea no good can
come of it specifically when you give it
to kids now we tried to ban alcohol
prohibition and that didn't work out so
they put stronger regulations on it
which is great so instead of banning
porn maybe put stronger regulations on
it making it harder for young kids to
access I don't think that banning porn
is a good idea same way as I believe
banning prostitution is a bad idea for
some people it's the only thing they
have if you if you for some people it's
the only thing they have okay well okay
Abraham first of all as I said yesterday
I'm fine with the idea of heavy
regulations that's better than nothing
not as good as a ban in my view but it's
a good step so we don't necessarily
disagree on that as to alcohol I'd argue
that alcohol and porn are very different
in a number of ways first of all I do
think that alcohol has redeeming
qualities and I'm not just talking about
the studies showing that you know a
glass of wine a few times a week is
healthy for you has health benefits
although that is an important point I
think but I think alcohol in moderation
can help facilitate social interaction
it has the effect of distressing people
a little bit loosening them up a bit
which could help with social interaction
again in moderation in fact this is a
true story I went to a doctor a few
years ago because I have chronic jaw
pain which which by the way I am a
victim for that so I do I do get a
place somewhere on the victim hierarchy
for my chronic jaw pain just so you know
keep that in mind the next time anyone
wants to criticize me or insult me
you're insulting a man with chronic jaw
pain you don't know my struggle so
anyway I went to the doctor for that and
I was told that there's really no
medicine they could prescribe but with
the doctor essentially prescribed
suggested is that she said well while
you have a drink when you get home at
night and it helps now I'm not trying to
claim that I drink primarily medicinally
although I have I could make that claim
but I don't I would probably have the
drink anyway but the point is there are
I think some benefits to having a drink
now again in moderation obviously if you
go overboard and you're getting drunk
then now you're an alcoholic and you're
destroying yourself and there are all
kinds of problems there which we're all
familiar with now porn you know you
could try to argue that it relieves
stress
I suppose I'm sure that there are people
that are gonna argue that now but
actually ultimately it doesn't people
who watch porn are more depressed on
average as studies have shown so porn
creates more stress than it reliefs and
whereas alcohol you know having a beer
with a friend you sit down with some
friends at a bar or something you have a
beer
nobody's getting drunk there's no
there's no downside nothing Bad's
happening and you're having a discussion
you're enjoying yourself
I could facilitate a wholesome social
environment porn does the opposite porn
is isolating it interferes with social
interaction it interferes with the sort
of cohesiveness of society in fact I
think it's one of the the reasons fewer
people date and get married these days
is because they're just looking at porn
instead and then and then also alcohol
is a physical product that can be locked
away it has to be bought in a store you
need an ID there are all kinds of
precautions that can be taken
they aren't 100% effective obviously but
my point is that it's a hell of a lot
easier to stop a 12 year old from
drinking a beer every night than it is
to stop at 12 year old from from looking
at porn and finally moderate
Bossier - alcohol even for a minor
really has no effect
so whereas moderate exposure to porn can
be traumatizing so compare you know
compare an eleven-year-old who sneaks a
swig of his dad's beer to an
eleven-year-old who sneaks a peek at
hardcore porn does anyone think that
they're gonna be equally damaged the
eleven-year-old who snuck a swig of the
beer which in fact i did that when i was
when i was around that age i wasn't
damaged by it at all in fact I hated it
I thought it was disgusting
and I didn't want to touch beer again
for a while because of how gross it was
that no ill effect didn't it didn't do
anything in my body which is just that
small tiny little bit of alcohol and
that's it wasn't traumatized by it it's
not something I'll be telling my
therapist about whereas in fact you've
already heard some of these emails just
that one brief exposure to our core porn
for a child can have a lasting effect
that they'll remember for the rest of
their life so I just think that these
two things are entirely different this
is from Luke's as Matt you said in
Monday's episode that government exists
for the good of society while I agree
how would you refute the point that free
health care and college would also be
good for society therefore we should
legislate it well I would say that it's
not good for society see this is my
point when the left makes an argument
and says we should do this for the
common good for the good of society
because it's morally right I think our
answer should be no it's not good it's
not morally right and here's why our
answer should not be and this is this is
unfortunately how conservatives often
answer
well conservatives will often do is
they'll say well who cares if it's the
right thing to do it's it's too
expensive that's at least that's how the
argument comes across often so we come
across like these utilitarian unfeeling
Scrooge's who say who cares that people
are starving to death is I that's all
it's all about the money the bottom line
that's the way it comes across no I
think
you see the moral arguments the
arguments from what is good and what is
right those are far more powerful far
more effective far more important it's
more important to do the right thing
morally than it is to do the the thing
that's going to be the most financially
advantageous so we should be engaging on
that level and so my response is you
know for example the tuition forgiveness
my answer is not oh yeah that'd be great
for society but I don't think we should
do it because I don't want you taking my
money your leeches no my answer is it'd
be horrible for society my answer is
it's it's morally wrong you're taking
money from from other people many of
them are not rich and can't afford it
you're taking money from them giving it
to someone else all these people have
made financial sacrifices to pay off
their their loans now you're gonna take
money from them to pay off of the loans
of people who haven't made those
sacrifices that is morally wrong because
your may these people are victims now
you're taking money from them it's it's
theft so that's my answer and I think
that that's gonna be a more effective
approach and also again it gets down
more to the heart of the matter this is
from Mike says Matt it's not true that
all laws are created to stop evil or
immoral acts some examples two or more
only in the carpool lane it's illegal to
start your car and let it warm up in
your driveway without being in it you
must have a garbage bag in your car you
must register your vehicle you must pay
an exorbitant tax in order to keep your
home or your vehicle these are just a
few laws that have nothing to do with
morality or the safety of others there
are dozens more now Mike remember I said
that that all laws have a moral basis
but it they can be incorrect obviously
there have been been many immoral laws
slavery was legal and that was an
immoral law but the people who
instituted those laws protecting slavery
would have claimed that it was moral and
that it was ultimately helping Society
it was the right thing to do
it was for the common good that's what
they
would have claimed they were hideously
wrong obviously and I don't think they
really even believed what they were
saying but the point is that pro the pro
slavery law ultimately did make a moral
claim did claim to be moral as all laws
do whether rightly or wrongly the people
who make laws can be wrong often are but
laws by their nature are rooted in a
moral conception good or bad conception
still a moral conception so the laws you
mentioned are definitely rooted in
morality two or more in the carpool lane
this is meant to make traffic more
orderly make things run smoother so
people can get where they're going
easier and safer why does that matter
you know why do we care about keeping
things safe and orderly on the highway
because it's morally right the thing
about the garbage bag in the car I've
never heard of that before I don't know
where that's a law I've just never heard
that
I assume the reason for that law I think
it's a stupid petty law if it exists but
presumably the reason is to stop people
from littering and so that is an attempt
at a moral law and then right down the
line taxes okay there are way too many
taxes there are a lot of bad taxes there
are a lot of immoral taxes but the
people who Institute taxes would say
they're doing it for the common good for
the benefit of society they might be
they might be lying but that's the claim
so again every time a law is passed
it is it is an attempt supposedly to do
something moral for the good of society
what you would need to do is find an
example of a law that at bottom is not
attempting to do anything moral at all a
a law that when it comes down to it has
no moral implications whatsoever and is
not intended to have moral implications
you would need to find an example of a
law like that and I don't think you can
finally this is from Genesis hi Matt
thank you for your episode on porn you
made a lot of great points and I mostly
agree with everything you say and I
agree that porn is a huge problem in
society my question is about hate speech
couldn't all of your arguments about
banning porn also be used to be
and hate speech so isn't there a
slippery slope there well Jenna I think
that there are some major differences
between hate speech and porn first of
all whereas I think porn is well
explicit literally hate speech is not
and so what I mean is we all know what
porn is when we see it there's little
confusion about it I'd wager that 99.9%
of the porn on the Internet is obviously
porn maybe there are some very rare
exceptions some gray areas and you're
always gonna have that with the law
you're always gonna have those those
fringe cases gray areas where you have
to stipulate there's a little bit of a
debate there but for the most part you
know what porn is there's not a lot of
confusion hate speech on the other hand
is entirely vague and ambiguous nobody
has a precise idea of what it is and the
judgment is completely subjective also
the character the categorization of of
hate speech depends on making judgments
about the intent of the speaker you are
assuming that the speaker was hateful in
what they said and in their intent in
saying it now sometimes that might be
obvious but often it isn't whereas the
intent behind porn is very clear to
everybody also I think that so-called
hate speech is clearly protected by the
First Amendment because it is speech
it's right there in the name it's the
expression of an idea a point of view
may be a bad idea maybe an offensive
point of view but it is speech nobody
can deny that because you can't even say
hate speech without admitting that it is
a form of speech now you can easily make
the argument as I did that porn is not
speech but you can't do that with hate
speech also policing hate speech
requires the government to police what
people say and what they think even
putting the the constitutional issues
aside I think this seems impossible to
me
policing porn is difficult but not
impossible it is a product published on
the Internet
publicly so this makes it at least
feasible at least possible to regulate
it or control it so I think those are
just some of the differences between
hate speech important and then maybe
what is this from Devin says I'd like to
get a look at your internet history
it's always the guy like the guys like
you who end up being into the freakiest
porn you're such a hypocrite I can't
believe I ever listen to your show
well Devin if you looked at my internet
history you'd find that I spend way too
much time reading analysis of the NFL
game from the previous weekend and it is
actually kind of embarrassing because I
spend a lot of time reading analyses of
games that people played I don't
actually watch porn and the fact that
you apparently think it's impossible for
a guy to not watch it says more about
you than me but this is also irrelevant
because as you heard him in these emails
plenty of guys watch it and yet agree
that it's bad and should be banned a
regulator or controlled are they
hypocrites no I would say that they are
admirably honest and courageous
courageous too to look honestly at what
they're doing see it for what it is and
speak out against it I think speaking
out against opposing your own behavior
is not hypocrisy so I find the testimony
of an anti porn man who watches porn to
be extremely compelling and I find it to
be far more compelling than dudes who
watch porn and want to defend it because
they like it that's really basic that's
easy to that that's just self-serving
and every Ness that that's easy to
figure out what's going on there but
someone who's coming out against their
own interests saying yes I enjoy doing
this well I don't maybe not enjoy it
anymore but I do it and yet I think I
should be stopped from doing it isn't
that really powerful testimony should it
make you stop and think now why would
people who do this be against it
and besides let's say that I am a
hypocrite so what would that make my
arguments wrong it's like we just talked
about with the pro-life thing our
arguments automatically wrong if they
come from the mouth of a hypocrite
see this is the laziest move what you're
doing here to impugn the motives of the
person making the argument rather than
to engage with the argument itself that
is lazy cheap stupid it's like if a
woman meant if a woman makes an argument
against abortion and then you find out
that that she had an abortion does that
make her argument about abortion wrong
she's making claims she's saying that
the unborn child is a human she's saying
that it's a person she's saying that
it's morally wrong to kill people these
are claims about science these are
claims about morality she's either right
or she's wrong and what she's done in
her past and what she does in her
private life is irrelevant to the truth
or falsehood of those claims and besides
it wouldn't even make her a hypocrite it
really makes her someone who has
experienced this has been down into that
darkness has seen it for what it is and
so that lends her argument more weight
not less it makes her more credible not
less her perspective is more interesting
just like the perspective of the men who
watch porn but are against it but is a
more interesting perspective and we can
learn a lot more from it than we can
from yours for example and final thing
this is just a pet peeve of me but but
but of mine and I don't mean to be
pedantic but this is not even what
hypocrisy is hypocrisy is not saying one
thing and doing another
that's not hypocracy so if I say that
it's wrong to tell a lie yet I've told
lies in my life that doesn't make me a
hypocrite hypocrisy is and if that does
make us make someone hypocrite then
we're all hypocrites and there's no
point of accusing anybody else of it
because we're all that and it's just
part of being a human which may
hypocrisy is part of being a human but
here's what hypocrisy actually is I
think it's far more insidious actually
hypocrisy is pretending to believe
something that you don't actually
believe so if somebody says something
and then does another thing that might
be evidence that they don't believe what
they said but not necessarily it could
just be evidence that they're weak and
because they're human and they have
trouble with follow-through like we all
do but that's what hypocrisy is
hypocrisy is a fraud a fake someone who
goes around Holt preaching a position
that they don't even really believe in
their heads and one thing I can
guarantee you is that I don't I don't
take positions that I don't believe so
at the very least a it's because I
believe it I might be wrong I might be
an idiot there's a lot of things you can
say about me but I very at the very
least you can be confident that what I'm
saying I I do at least believe it I
might be the only one who believes that
the betting on what it is but at least I
do otherwise I wouldn't be saying all
right we'll leave it there thanks for
the email Devin and thanks everybody
else for tuning in Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer austin stevens editor donovan
fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
despite all of their charges collapsing
Democrats plan to move forward with two
articles of impeachment against
President Trump we will examine why it's
happening now how did we get to the
point where we can't agree on anything
some people blame Trump some blame the
IG report some are blaming a week
Democratic field the real root cause is
far deeper we will examine how this rot
has been building since at least the
1980s check it out on the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]
you